teams a b and c are playing a game of
strength each team has attached a rope
to a metal ring and is trying to pull
the ring into their own area team areas
shown below so let's see what that's so
we see that over here team a is pulling
on the ring in that direction team b is
pulling on the ring in that direction
team c is pulling on the ring in that
direction they're each trying to get the
ring into
into their respective areas it's a
three-way tug of war
they tell us team a pulls with the force
vector a of four times the unit vector i
plus zero j so this is four times
there's no vertical component here so
it's going straight in the positive i
guess you could say x direction and we
can see it right over there a is going
straight in the positive x direction
it's just a multiple of the unit vector
i
team b pulls with force vector negative
2i plus 4j so it's to the left and up
and we see that negative 2i plus 4j
then we have team c pulls with a force
vector negative 3i minus 3j so let's see
negative 3i
minus 3j
yep that seems consistent with the
diagram
forces are given in kilonewtons all
right which team will win the game
so to think about which team will win
the game we have to think about which
one is pulling with the most magnitude
in their direction so let me get my
little scratch pad out and let's think
about the magnitudes of each of these
vectors
so let's first think about the magnitude
of vector a
what is that going to be
well it's 4 times the unit vector i it's
going to have so it's just going to have
a magnitude of four the unit vector i
has a magnitude of one so its magnitude
is just four times that its magnitude is
equal to four and let's put the units
there it's four
kilonewtons
now what about the magnitude of vector b
the magnitude of vector b
well we can use the pythagorean theorem
it's negative 2 i
plus
plus 4 j
so the magnitude squared is going to be
negative 2 squared plus 4 squared which
is really just coming out of the
pythagorean theorem so the magnitude
of vector b
is going to be equal to the square root
of
negative 2 squared
plus 4 or one way you think about this
is the pythagorean theorem or the
distance formula between the origin and
that point right over there plus 4
squared that's 4 plus 16. this is the
square root of 20.
and let's see this is definitely greater
than 4. 4 squared is just 16. this is
someplace between 4 and 5.
and let's see team c
the magnitude of vector c
same logic is going to be the square
root of negative 3 squared
plus negative 3 squared which is equal
to let's see this is square root of 18
right 9 plus 9 square root of 18.
so square root of 20 is clearly larger
than square root of 18 and we already
said that square root of 20 is larger is
larger than four so team b is going to
win which team will win the game
team
b and we can even let's just fill it out
on our
team b is going to win the game
now the next thing they ask us is what
is the magnitude of the team's combined
forces acting on the ring
well to figure that out we can just add
up all of these vectors the the combined
force so let's write this so the force
let's say force combined let's this is a
vector it's going to be the sum of
vectors a
plus vector b
plus b
plus c
which is going to be equal to
i
plus 0 j
plus
or minus 2 i
minus 2 i
plus 4j
minus 3i
minus 3
j
and so now we can just add up the
the i's and add up the js
so we have 4i
minus 2i
minus
3i so 4 of something minus 2 you're
going to have 2 left then you subtract
another 3 you're going to have negative
1 of that so that's going to be equal to
negative i could write negative 1i or
just negative i
and then we have
zero j's plus four j's minus three j's
so that's well zero plus four minus
three is just going to be 1j or you
could say just plus
j so that's the resulting vector here is
negative i plus j so it might look
something like this so negative
negative i
plus j
gets us a vector
gets us a vector that looks like that
and let me actually draw it a little bit
bigger here
so if i were to draw
if i were to draw our coordinate axes
that's my y axis
this is my
x-axis
it's negative 1 times i so let's say it
looks like that that's negative i
that's negative i right over there
negative i
let me write that that is negative i
plus j
plus j plus the j unit vector which
might look something like this both of
them have a magnitude of one so that is
the j unit vector
and the sum of those two is our combined
force
our combined force
is going to be going it's going to be
going into this direction
so as this is its magnitude so the
length of it is its magnitude combined
force and that goes in line with we're
going to be going in that direction
which takes us to the zone of b but they
ask us what is the magnitude of the
team's combined force
well
the magnitude of this side is one it's a
unit vector where it's going in the left
direction the magnitude of this side is
one so the magnitude of this side we
just use the pythagorean theorem it's
the square root of one squared plus one
squared which is just the square root
square root of two so the magnitude here
what is the magnitude of the t combined
the team's combined forces is square
root of two in what direction is the
ring getting pulled and actually let me
just fill out what they're what they've
already asked us just so we can
so what is the magnitude of the team's
combined force acting on the ring round
to the nearest tenth so let's just write
square root of two
is equal to
and round to the nearest tenth one point
four kilonewtons
1.4 kilonewtons and what direction is
the ring getting pulled and they want to
send radians round to the nearest tenth
your answer should be between 0 and 2 pi
radians so that
go back to our diagram we need to figure
out we need to figure out what this
angle is right over here we need to
figure out what that angle is in radians
and we know
we know that this whole thing if we went
from the positive x-axis all the way to
the negative x-axis that is pi
radians and we also know what this angle
right over here is how do we know that
well i've just constructed a notice this
is a right angle and this is an
isosceles triangle isosceles right
triangle it's going to be a 45
45 90 triangle but if you're thinking in
terms of radians 45 degrees is pi over
4.
so this is pi over 4
pi over 4
pi over 2 triangle same thing as 45 45
90. so this whole purple angle is pi and
this is pi over 4 you just subtract the
pi over 4 from the pi to get what theta
is
so theta
is going to be equal to pi is the same
thing as 4 pi
over four
minus pi over four
minus pi over four i just did that to
get a common denominator which is equal
to three pi over four
three
pi over four radians so let's go back
over here now they want us to round it
to the nearest tenth so let's take three
three times pi
divided by let's make sure you can see
what i'm doing here so three times pi
divided by 4
is equal to
2.356 around to the nearest tenth
would be 2.4 radians so approximately
2.4
radians and
we got it right